Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and during my
Game Of Thrones episode 7 video I asked you
all to submit questions so I picked 10 of
them to include in this video and one bonus
question.
Also congratulations to Leslie Hernandez , you’re
this week’s giveaway winner.
You win a $20 Amazon Giftcard.
I’ll be messaging you on your channel for
details.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time.
I do Q&As like this for most of my biggest
stuff like Game of Thrones or if there’s
something special you guys want to talk more
about.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to leave me suggestions for bonus
videos.
After the Q&A I’ll have an update on my
schedule this week.
It’s going to be a little weird, but there’s
some cool stuff coming.
So let’s answers some Moon Door Questions,
careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go Question 1 - Sarah asks What do
you think Melisandre will do with Stannis'
daughter?
I don’t remember that from the books.
I think Melisandre is going to try and sacrifice
her to gain some boon from the Red God.
It seems like her using Royal Blood makes
her spells much more powerful.
Like when she used Stannis to make the shadow
baby, she probably couldn’t have done that
with any normal person.
It had to be someone with Royal Blood.
The show doesn’t really explain why, only
that Royal Blood is special in the eyes of
the Red God.
It’s a lot like the way a Cleric prays to
a God for their powers and the god grants
them power for a short period of time.
That’s they way I view Melisandre and Thoros’
abilities.
It’s not like sorcery where you get your
powers from a mystical place.
As for what she’s hoping to get from Shireen’s
royal blood I can’t say.
I think it’s just to make their army stronger.
To assure victory.
Question 2 - Pizza Dalek says I think Littlefinger
kissed Sansa because he knew Lysa was watching
and it was all part of a big scheme.
He kissed her for a bunch of reasons.
Part because he was working a long con to
get rid of Lysa, she was just a means to an
end.
But he also has really conflicted feelings
about Sansa.
He said it all in his speech there.
She is for him several things, the daughter
he never had.
And a much more beautiful version of the only
woman he ever loved.
So he’s part sentimental, part creeper.
As for how Sansa feels about all this, I’d
say she’s just shocked and doesn’t know
what’s going on.
Remember, she’s learning to be a pessimist
but she still has a lot of that innocence
left in her.
So she’s not even thinking about Littlefinger
trying to get rid of Lysa.
Question 3 - Kirsten Knightley asks why did
Daenerys let the Masters keep their power
and wealth?
They made it seem like she crucified those
few hundred arbitrarily, like she didn’t
give them a trial.
She just said you hung up X number of slaves
so I’m going to hang up X number of slave
masters.
I think the show is going to explain a little
more about her relationship with the rest
of the slaving families in Meereen.
She’s the current power in the city, so
a lot of them are just sucking up to her like
sycophants in King’s Landing do with the
Iron Throne.
She really did kill a lot of them though.
But all of the slaving families have sons
like Hizdhar, so killing the fathers just
means the sons will take over.
So if she really wanted to get rid of slaving
completely, she’d have to kill all of the
families.
Which is way way more people and as much of
a badass as she is, I don’t think she’s
prepared to murder that many people.
She is giving them the chance to accept her
rule.
Question 4 - Relle Laron asks Do you think
we’ll see Gendry this season?
I hope so, there was a tweet that Joe Dempsie
wrote saying he worked with a bunch of awesome
people this year and one of them was Maisie
Williams.
I think it’s okay to assume he was talking
about Game of Thrones because the only other
project on her IMDB page doesn’t list Joe
Dempsie as a cast member.
It’s more likely that he just has a greatly
reduced role.
Remember, the last time we saw him, he was
rowing for King’s Landing from Dragonstone.
So it’s possible he could have been picked
up by a ship or he really will make it back
to King’s Landing.
They’ve already changed his character from
the books a lot, so I don’t want to try
and predict too many things about him.
Question 5 - Bloody Desires asks Did Brienne
choose to follow Pod's suggestion about Sansa
being with her aunt?
Yes, it was really subtle, but they are heading
for the Vale.
It’s possible that they could catch up to
Arya and the Hound.
I don’t think it will be as simple as them
just finding Sansa at the Vale.
That seems too nice of an ending for Game
of Thrones.
So I’m planning on something terrible happening
on their journey.
Either they run into the Brotherhood and someone
dies, or they run into Arya and the Hound
and someone dies.
Someone is probably going to die.
Question 6 - Declan Asks could you explain
who Lolly’s Stokeworth is?
I saw a bunch of people in the comments asking
about Lollys.
She’s a minor character from King’s Landing
in the books.
In season 2 when all the peasants rioted and
tried to kill Joffrey, in the books.
Her character is brutalized by the mob.
She’s from a noble house, but after the
mob attack, no one is willing to marry her.
But Bronn comes along and Cersei tries to
win him over, to turn against Tyrion by offering
him a title and a castle and marriage to Lollys.
So Bronn is marrying into money, and as you
can see, he’s not too picky about his women.
They cut her character out of the show is
all.
Until now.
Question 7 - Nicholas asks What was the Mountain
doing with all those guys?
He was executing them for petty crimes.
Like normally you would just lock people up.
The Mountain was just slaughtering them like
Cattle.
The reason it’s so terrible is because they
all probably just committed minor crimes.
The Mountain is like a crazier version of
ser Illyn Payne.
Payne is the King’s executioner.
But he has scruples.
The Mountain is who you call when you want
someone killed, no questions asked.
He’s like a fixer for the Lannisters.
Fixing inconvenient problems.
They showed that scene just to let us know
how crazy dangerous he is.
Question 8 - Nathan asks Why do Lysa and her
son seem to have years of inbreeding in their
blood?
All royals have a certain level of interbreeding
going on.
Like there aren’t that many people to pick
from to marry from other families over the
course of the centuries without you ending
up being related to everyone else at some
point.
But Lysa is a Stark, so she’s not born of
incest or anything.
And she wasn’t related to John Arryn when
they were married.
So technically Robyn isn’t a twincest baby
like Joffrey.
He’s just super nutters.
In the books, Tyrion describes Lysa as being
‘touched’ as in she’s crazy.
Just mentally disturbed.
That’s why Littlefinger has had such an
easy time of manipulating her over the years.
Although he probably contributed to some of
her psychosis.
Question 9 - Ashley asks, could you explain
Oberyn’s speech about baby Tyrion more?
So Tyrion is several years younger than Oberyn,
Jaime and Cersei.
So when he was born at Casterly Rock it just
happend to coincide with a vist from the Martells.
Oberyn would have been a little boy.
They were just visiting the Lannisters.
But while they were on their way, Tyrion was
born and his mother died.
So everyone at Casterly Rock including Cersei
started telling stories about Tyrion being
a monster and killing their mother.
They don’t explain Cersei’s thought process
a lot, other than she decides to put all of
her negative feelings for her mother dying
on Tyrion.
She just blames him.
Jaime does not.
So Oberyn goes to see Tyrion in his cradle
and just like Jaime, decides that Tyrion isn’t
a monster at all, he’s just a little baby.
They’re just trying to show that Oberyn
has a lot of compassion.
As opposed to Cersei.
Question 10 - Nick asks Do you think Bran
would ever be able to warg into one of Daenerys’
dragons?
They don’t explain the science of it too
well, but it’s implied that a lot of it
has to do with the mental strength of the
vessel.
So it would be a lot harder for Bran to Warg
into a person of normal intelligence.
As opposed to Hodor whole has a much more
primitive brain.
It depends on how smart the Dragons are.
They seem like they’re a lot more powerful
than the direwolves.
So I think Bran would have to be a lot better
at it.
Like becoming a more powerful Jedi before
you can take down Vader and the Emperor.
Bonus Question - Bombay Theme asks, What did
Daenerys mean when she told Jorah to tell
Daario he changed her mind?
She was originally going to have Daario execute
all the Wise Masters in Yunkai but Jorah reasoned
that her new followers would just see it as
more brutality and revolt against her.
So his idea was to at least give them the
choice to accept Daenerys’ terms.
Daenerys was just throwing him a bone by telling
him to tell Daario that he changed her mind.
I think she feels a little guilty about favoring
Daario now.
When Jorah has been loyal to her for so long.
She she’s just showing him that she hasn’t
forgotten about him completely.
So thanks so much everyone for submitting
questions.
Remember, there’s no new episode for two
weeks.
So this weekend I’ll just do a bonus video
instead.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And if you guys want I’ll do another Q&A
too.
Just let me know.
I’ll be traveling from Thursday through
Sunday, so there will probably only be one
video each day for those days but I’ll try
to post updates on my schedule on social.
Links for all that in the description.
Right now click here for my episode 7 video
and click here to learn all about the Wildlings.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!